almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it let's talk
now about the Rand Paul story I
mentioned earlier Kentucky Republican
Senator Rand Paul yesterday when on Fox
News and he chose feelings over facts I
thought they were the facts over
feelings people Rand Paul had a very
embarrassing day in total yesterday
there had they had a Senate hearing
where doctor foul Chi dr. Redfield and
others testified and Rand Paul sort of
scolded Anthony foul she telling him you
know you're not the end-all you just
want opinion and we got to look at what
other countries are doing as well
including Sweden which we'll talk about
but then Rand Paul went on Fox News in
the evening to talk about the new
so-called Obama gate scandal this is a
totally fake trumped-up scandal to
distract from Donald Trump's incredible
failure on coronavirus and Rand Paul
asserts to martha maccallum that Barack
Obama gave direct oversight and guidance
on unmasking Donald Trump's former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
the Fox News host Martha McCallum asks
the right question which is do you have
evidence of that and Rand Paul says I'm
not I'm not kidding you're gonna see
here I have a strong feeling he has a
feeling but no facts take a look at it
Trump campaign I really strongly believe
that President Obama gave specific and
direct oversight and direct permission
for this think about it we have never
allowed a secret court to be used
against the presidential cat
campaign don't you think that was
sensitive enough that it went all the
way to the very top so yeah the media
have treated President Obama with kid
gloves someone needs to ask him directly
did you approve a prophet of Operation
crossfire hurricane I think the answer
is yes so you know I mean to put the
shoe on the other foot a lot of these do
you have evidence of that you say you're
sure that the president the former
president was involved in this why are
you so sure well we'll find out I'm
that a lot of this will be declassified
but I have a strong feeling that this
was such a sensitive subject he's
already admitted or admitted through
people that worked for him that the
Flint investigation he knew a lot about
and I strongly believe I think the
answer is yes but do you have evidence
well no but I have a feeling this is
downright irresponsible for a sitting
u.s. senator to be saying if Rand Paul
had a shred of evidence for his claims
he would have provided it by now but he
doesn't have any evidence so instead he
has his feelings
since when do sitting senators go on
television and accused former presidents
of wrongdoing allegedly criminal
wrongdoing on the basis of feelings I
guess now is the answer to that
so that was Rand Paul choosing feelings
over facts on Fox News earlier in the
day here is Rand Paul going after doctor
foul Qi remember that Rand Paul got
coronavirus while he was waiting for his
test results he went to the Senate gym
and worked out turns out he was positive
during that workout now he's refusing to
wear a mask and here he is scolding
doctor foul Qi during yesterday's Senate
hearing as I respect you dr. Falchi I
don't think you're the end-all I don't
think you're the one person that gets to
make a decision we can listen to your
advice but there are people on the other
side saying there's not going to be a
serves and then we can safely open the
economy and the facts well to bear this
out but if we keep kids out of school
for another year what's going to happen
is that the poor and underprivileged
kids you don't have a parent that is
able to teach them at home are not going
to learn for a full year and I think
you've got to look at the Swedish model
and we ought to look at our kids get
back to skwiggs a huge mistake if we
don't know them in the schools in the
fall thank you now Rand Paul mentions
Sweden talk about Sweden a little bit
Sweden much like chloroquine has become
a political football and for me just
like with chloroquine I have no
emotional attachment to Sweden did the
right thing or Sweden didn't do the
right thing what happened in Sweden is
that older and vulnerable folks isolated
and stayed at home but young people
mostly haven't there's been mild social
distancing in bars and restaurants
schools stayed open young people for the
most part lived close to their normal
lives what do we know so far
well so far Sweden's death rate is the
ninth highest in the world
if you eliminate tiny countries like San
Marino and Andorra Sweden's death rate
right now is the sixth highest in the
world out of more than a hundred and
eighty countries so what we can say is
that so far at this point in the
pandemic Sweden's plan has led to a
really high death rate now let's be fair
does that mean
Sweden's plan failed not necessarily
because it's possible it's possible that
because Sweden is doing this and having
more a higher death rate now it could
get them more immunity and potentially
potentially Sweden could end up with
lower deaths during wave 2 and wave 3 if
there is one so I again I just want the
truth
if Sweden's plan worked then great we
should all know it if it didn't work
then we should all know it's so far
Sweden's death rate is very high but if
they end up with more immunity by the
time wave two hits which could wave to
could be worse than wave one we don't
know yet Sweden may end up in the long
term for the total pandemic they could
end up with a lower death rate we just
don't know yet now doctor foul he
responded i he also doesn't think he's
the be-all end-all he's just a public
health professional here's how he
handled it first of all Senator Paul
thank you for your comments I have never
made myself out to be the end-all and
only voice of this I'm a scientist
a physician and a public health official
I give advice according to the best
scientific evidence there are a number
of other people who come into that and
give advice that are more related to the
things that you spoke about about the
need to get the country back open again
and economically I don't give advice
about economic things I don't give
advice about anything other than public
health so I wanted to respond to that
the second thing is that you use the
word we should be humble about what we
don't know and I think that falls under
the fact that we don't know everything
about this virus and we really better be
very careful particularly when it comes
to children so I think you get the idea
Anthony foul me not getting rattled by
Rand Paul making him
the enemy I know we talked about this
but what kind of a sick country are we
that a doctor who's been doing this for
decades and has worked for I think it's
six presidents is now the enemy bogus
documentaries are being made where dr.
pouchy is the villain people are
attempting to concoct false sexual
assault allegations against dr. fowey as
I told you about earlier
crowds protests are screaming fire foul
Chi yesterday I did a story about the
world is laughing at us the treatment of
health experts by the Trump crowd during
this pandemic is a big part of why the
world is laughing at us
absolutely sick and a notice of course
that dr. Fauci has now been gone for
weeks from any Trump administration
press briefing coronavirus task force
event he's still doing interviews he
testified before the Senate but he has
been disappeared as we talked to you
about a couple of weeks ago